- [Instructor] We're told
that Hannah and Martine
each got a plant for their home.
Hannah measured that her plant grows,
on average, 2 centimeters per week.
Martine measured that her plant grows,
on average, 3 millimeters per day.
Which plant grows faster?
Pause this video and see
if you can figure that out on your own.
All right, now let's go
through this together.
So at first when you look at it,
you might just compare 3 to 2
and say, oh, 3 is larger than 2,
therefore maybe Martine's
plant grows faster.
And you would think that
until you look at the units.
This is millimeters per day
while for Hannah's plant
it's in centimeters per week.
So in order to really compare them
we have to convert them to the same units
in both length and time.
So let's convert both of them,
let's convert them both
to centimeters per week.
You could just try to convert both of them
to millimeters per day
or I guess you could try
to convert both of them
to meters per year, a third set of units,
but centimeters per week seems reasonable
since we already have
Hannah's plant rate at,
so let me write this down.
So Hannah, I'll just write H,
grows at 2 centimeters per week.
And then you have Martine,
grows at an average of
3 millimeters per day.
Now how do we convert
3 millimeters per day
to centimeters per week?
Well, first we could
convert the millimeters,
actually, first, let's
convert the days into weeks.
So how many days are there in a week?
Well, there's 7 days in a week.
So if we have how many
millimeters per day,
if we wanted to know millimeters per week
we would multiply times 7 days.
So let me do that.
So times 7 days
in a week.
That would get us,
this would be equal to 3 times 7
which is equal to 21 millimeters
in a week.
And you can see, actually,
that the units cancel
out nicely like that,
so you're left with millimeters a week.
And that makes sense, 3 millimeters a day,
you're able to do 7 times that in a week,
21 millimeters a week.
And then when you think
about 21 millimeters
is how many centimeters?
Well, we just have to remember
that 1 centimeter is
equal to 10 millimeters,
so if we wanna covert
this into centimeters,
we essentially have to divide by 10.
We could just say 1/10 of
a centimeter per millimeter
and then that gets us,
we could write it in different ways,
but we could write this,
and even here the units cancel out nicely,
21 divided by 10 is 2.1
centimeters per week.
Another way you could
have just thought about it
is we could say 1 centimeter
is equal to 10 millimeters,
or if you divide both sides by 10,
1/10 of a centimeter is
equal to 1 millimeter,
and if 1 millimeter is equal
to 1/10 of a centimeter
then 21 millimeters is just
going to be 21 times this,
21 times 1/10 is the same
thing as 21 divided by 10,
it would be 2.1 centimeters.
And so now we can compare
2.1 centimeters per week
compared to 2 centimeters a week.
Well, it turns out that
when you actually compare
the appropriate units
it still turns out that Martine's plant
is growing just a little bit faster.